-Welcome back
to "The Tonight Show."
I'm Steve Higgins, and we're
about to play "Pup Quiz."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[ Dogs barking ]
Aww.
Playing tonight, we have
the host of "The Tonight Show,"
Mr. Jimmy Fallon.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh.
And his opponent,
the star of
"John Wick: Chapter 4,"
premiering in theaters and IMAX
March 24th, Keanu Reeves.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Aww.
Okay.
This is the first puppy
up tonight.
Named Gary Frick Jr.
[ Audience "Awws" ]
And here's how it's gonna work.
I'll be asking both of you
animal trivia questions.
[ Audience "Awws" ]
And if you answer correctly,
you will receive
a golden retriever puppy.
[ Audience "Awws" ]
-That's the way it works.
-If you answer incorrectly,
your opponent gets the puppy.
And whoever has the most puppies
at the end of the game
is the Pup Quiz champion.
Keanu, since you're our guest,
you'll answer the first question
and either win or lose
Mr. Gary Frick Jr.
-Okay.
-What is the only species
of reptile --
-I'm so terrible with this.
[ Laughter ]
-Wait.
He didn't even finish
the question.
-I know. I just know it's just
gonna be a disaster.
-No, come on.
-It's just -- go ahead.
-You're gonna get this one.
What is the only species
of reptile native to Ireland.
Is it, A, snake...
-Come on.
-...B, lizard, or, C, turtle?
Not sea turtle.
C, turtle.
-Native to Ireland.
Okay.
So all of those are kind of,
like, the thing and what's
gonna be the thing,
and then what's the thing that
you don't think it's gonna be,
so you're gonna say turtle.
-Right.
But then you're gonna
change your answer to...
-Uh, uh, lizard.
[ Laughter ]
-Lizard. Yes!
Lizard is correct!
[ Cheers and applause ]
You win Gary Frick Jr.
-Hey, buddy.
-Come on.
This is not fair.
First of all,
I'm not taking a puppy
away from John Wick.
[ Laughter ]
Just saying that right now.
-Okay.
This next question's for you,
Jimmy.
-Okay.
-Where you going?
-Which of the following species
is not the name
of a real animal?
Okay?
Which of the following
is not the name
of a real animal species?
Is it, A, sarcastic fringehead,
B, spiny lumpsucker,
or, C, shorty bobbit.
-The following is not the name
of a real animal species.
I think it's
sarcastic fringehead.
-Sarcastic fringehead.
Is that your final answer?
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-It is?
-No!
Answer was shorty bobbit.
Oh, shorty bobbit.
[ Audience "Ohs" ]
Now Keanu wins the adorable
puppy, Mary Kennedy.
-Oh.
Do they know each other?
Do the puppies know each other?
Is this, like, a common litter?
-We have like
50 puppies backstage.
[ Laughter ]
-You got Gary and Mary.
[ Dog barking ]
Oh, my gosh! Do you hear that?
-No.
-That sound means it's time
for Double Puppardy.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-Double Puppardy?
-Questions are now worth
two puppies.
[ Laughter ]
-Watch out.
-Keanu.
-What?
-A dik-dik...
[ Laughter ]
A dik-dik is what kind
of animal?
Is it, A, platypus --
A platypus.
B, is for bird, or C, antelope,
not cantaloupe.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay. So, you do the one
that you think it's gonna be,
but then you pick the one that
you don't think it's gonna be,
and then you pick the one that
and then the dik-dik
is an antelope.
-That is correct!
[ Ding! ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Are you out of your mind?
-Keanu, you and Lisa McAdams
and Lisa Armstrong.
-Double Puppardy.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow.
-Let's go, Fallon.
-Come here, boy.
That's it. Come here, boy.
That's a good boy.
-It's puppy love!
-You give that one back --
-That's my puppy, Fallon!
-I love it.
-All right, next question
goes to Jimmy.
Why do males dogs raise their
leg when is they urinate?
[ Laughter ]
Is it, A, to tell others
they are tall?
Is it, B, to tell other dogs
they are happy?
Or it is, C, to tell other dogs
they are DTF.
[ Laughter ]
Down to fetch.
-Maybe, uh, B?
-No, it's to tell other dogs
they are tall.
[ Sad tuba ]
So, Keanu, you get Roger Blaine
and Ted Mooney.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Can you help the dogs?
-Hi.
-Who's the puppy king?
-Come here.
There you go.
-I'm the puppy king!
-There we go.
He's got 'em.
All right.
[ Laughs ]
-Hey, buddy.
-Okay.
[ Dog barking ]
Oh, my gosh!
That sound means it's time
for Final Puppardy.
This is for all your opponent's
puppies and the game.
So pick up your iPads
if you can.
[ Laughter ]
How many dogs were used
to film the movie "Air Bud"?
All right.
You'll have 10 seconds
on the clock starting now.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
-They left, they left.
They just left.
They left.
-Oh!
-They left, okay?
They're wandering --
[ Buzzer ]
It's chaos.
I'm gonna say 10.
-Keanu, what did you write down?
-Uh, 6, but if it's not 6,
then it's a 9.
[ Laughter ]
-The answer is 6!
[ Ding! ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
-There we go.
My thanks to Keanu Reeves,
these adorable puppies.
Stick around! We'll be right
back with Melanie Lynskey!
Congratulations.
-How's it going?
Yeah.